hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast primary HPV cervical cancer
screening supporting data and guidance
updates I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by roche molecular
diagnostics we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in a lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Julia
angstrom Melnick medical and scientific
affairs at roche diagnostics corporation
i will now turn it over to julia for her
presentation thank you Judy and welcome
to the day to today's webinar we're at
an exciting time for HPV as for cervical
cancer screening in 2014 the first HPV
test was approved for primer HPV
screening indication and now in 2015 we
have the first published interim
guidance for the use of primary HPV so
the Pap test was first introduced by dr.
Bates and Papanikolaou in the 1920s soon
after it became evident this technique
could potentially reduce the burden of
cervical cancers by finding developing
cases allowing for earlier treatment and
proven
getting further progression countries
began introducing screening programs
based on this test in the 1950s and in
1975 ACOG issued the first cervical
cancer screening recommendations annual
pap testing for women 18 years and older
the adoption has led to dramatic
reductions in cervical cancer rates but
despite the tremendous success of
cervical cancer screening there's still
a need to reduce the cancer rates
further the most significant is an
access to screening the majority of
women diagnosed with cervical cancer
within both the Kaiser patient
registering the Swedish national health
registry either had not been screened or
did not receive a recent screen in the
left five years but cervical cancer
still occurs in women that have been
screened in both of these audits we see
that about thirty-two percent in the
Kaiser and about twenty four percent in
the Swedish system we're due to failures
of cytology based screening so it's
important to understand the limitations
of the tests we use if we hope to
improve upon them it is well known that
one of the main limitations of cytology
is its low sensitivity for detecting
high-grade disease in fact there have
been multiple attempts to help improve
its sensitivity over the years including
work load limits liquid-based cytology
and computer-assisted screening however
these attempts have done little to
impact the overall low sensitivity of
cytology or in the detection of ais and
adenocarcinoma also because cytology
relies on a subjective into impression
of cellular changes and cervical cancer
precursors as they occur there is often
very low reproducibility cytology can
identify women with advanced disease but
not provide insights
as to who may be a risk of developing
this in the future therefore cytology
has a very limited long-term predictive
value so despite the implementation of
cytology based screening the incidence
of adenocarcinoma is increasing this
demonstrates a cytology based screening
methods are missing adenocarcinoma and
its precursors lesions most likely due
to sampling limitations and an
under-representation of grindr glandular
cells sampling bias has greater
implications when a less sensitive
method is used the subjectivity of
cytology is demonstrated on this slide
as part of the alts trial the National
Cancer Institute had about 5,000 slides
of reread by second-sight a pathologist
each reviewer interpreted slide slightly
differently with only about seventy
eight percent of slides originally
classified as normal we're considered
normal or negative by the second side of
pathologist and as expected the
reproducibility of the equivocal
diagnosis of askest was fairly low at
forty-three percent what's most
compelling of this is that only
forty-seven percent of the sides
originally classified as high grade were
diagnosed as high grade on review
needless to say cytology based screening
has been very successful despite the
fact that the underlying cause of the
disease was not known in the 1970s
Harold zur hausen first published the
his hypothesis between the link of HPV
and cervical cancer and since then there
has been tremendous amount of research
and our knowledge in this area has grown
exponentially in fact in 1995 the
International Agency for the research on
cancer which is part of the wh 0
classified HPV 16
and 18 as carcinogenic and concluded
that HPV infection is a necessary cause
of cervical cancer today we know we now
know that almost all cervical cancers
are caused by small subset of HPV
genotypes the association between HPV
and cervical cancer is extraordinarily
strong for example the odds of having
cervical cancer if a woman to HPV 16
positive versus an HPV negative woman is
435 and if we compare that to the odds
of a male smoker versus a nonsmoker for
developing lung cancer of only eight in
fact just to HPV genotypes HPV 16 and
HPV 18 are responsible for approximately
seventy percent of all cervical cancers
so with this background the FDA approved
the first HPV test in 1999 and since
then cervical cancer guidelines continue
to evolve to provide data-driven
recommendations the highlight that the
preferred method for screening includes
an HPV test additionally algorithms also
incorporate HPV 16 and HPV 18 genotyping
with our evolving understanding of HPV
and despite growing awareness of
cervical cancer limitations cytology
based screening remains one of the most
widely used screening modalities however
based on the limitations of cytology
part of the 2011 cervical cancer
screening guideline cytology screening
at a three-year interval is now
considered an acceptable option for
women 30 to 65 but is no longer
indicated as preferred
for women 21 to 29 it's a recommended
screening option due to concerns are in
excessive HPV positivity in younger
women however new data have since become
available that provides an approach that
makes HPV testing a viable option for
these younger women for women 30 to 65
incorporating HPV testing alongside the
pap is considered the preferred method
in these 2011 screening guidelines the
use of HPV test increases the
sensitivity of the initial screen and
allows for extended screening intervals
cytology negative and HPV positive women
should be followed up with either repeat
code testing in 12 months or immediate
HPV 16 and 18 genotyping if immediate
HPV genotyping women testing positive
for HPV 16 or eight 1618 should be
referred directly to colposcopy whereas
women with negative results should be co
tested in 12 months HPV testing provides
several bem benefits over cytology due
to higher sensitivity incorporating HPV
DNA testing leads to a reduction in the
detection of cin 3 or greater or cancer
in subsequent rounds of screening which
allows for longer safety intervals HPV
DNA testing improves detection of ais
and adenocarcinoma and HPV is the first
necessary cause of a human cancer ever
identified its presence identifies women
at risk of developing cervical cancer
and it can also help determine who which
women are at the highest risk and more
importantly its absence provides
reassurance of low short and long term
cervical cancer risk
in fact HPV DNA testing reduces the
incidence of invasive cervical cancer
compared to cytology here's the pooled
data from for large-scale European
randomized trials which included over a
hundred seventy six thousand women in
over 1.2 million person years of
follow-up between two and three years
after screening there begins to be an
increase in the detection of invasive
cervical cancer and women who are
cytology negative a baseline which is
the gray line versus the women who are
HPV negative which is the blue line
overall HPV DNA based screening reduced
the cervical cancer rates by sixty to
seventy percent demonstrating that when
compared to cytology based screening HPV
DNA testing offers greater safety and
reduces long-term incidents of cervical
cancer it should be noted that the
benefit of a combined cytology and HPV
test is predominantly due to the
negative predictive value of the HPV
test as a risk is not dramatically
improved when cytology is added to the
HPD test when it comes to risk of
cervical cancer there is no statistical
difference HPV testing alone provides
the same reassurance against cervical
cancer as a co test in 2014 the FDA
approved the first HPV DNA test for
primer HPD screening indication based on
improved safety of this strategy over
cytology based screening in response
following review of the FDA's submission
data and newly published findings from
their several large-scale studies SGO
and a sccp jointly published interim
guidance for the use of primary HPV
screening this guidance document
affirmed that HPV primary screening is
an option for women
five years and older this is the
algorithm described describing the
guidance document for women 25 years and
older HPV test FDA approved for primary
screening indication would be used in
conjunction with HPV 16 and 18
genotyping this not only relies on the
more sensitive and non subjective test
as the first line test but also
incorporates immediate risk
stratification women testing negative
have a very low risk of cervical
pre-cancer look at the time of screening
and over the next few years and so they
should not be screened sooner than three
years women positive for HPV 16 + or 18
with are those women at the highest risk
of cervical pre-cancer and cancer and
should be referred for colposcopy for
additional follow-up women HPV positive
but negative for HPV 16 and 18 are at a
much lower risk but they're not without
risk cytology is used to triage these
women to identify which one which ones
in a subset have detectable cellular
changes that would warrant immediate
colposcopy so this guidance document was
developed based on extensive literature
and data review and in discussion with
representatives from seven different
professional societies they determined
that primary HPV screening is an
alternative to current cervical cancer
screening methods due to equivalent or
superior effectiveness a negative
high-risk HPV test provides greater
reassurance of low CIN 3 or greater risk
than a negative cytology result primary
HPV screening can include women 25 to 29
and they also highlighted that only
fda-approved assays with specific
primary HPV screening indication should
be used
the effectiveness of primary HPV
screening is mainly determined by the
risks associated with a negative
screening result risk of cin 3 or
greater over 3 years following a
negative HPV test at baseline which is
the lower curve in blue is half that
following a negative path at baseline
which is the upper curve in gray as as
expected the rise in the slope is much
more pronounced following a negative pap
than a negative HPV result highlighting
that long-term risk assessment is
limited when only assessing current cell
abnormalities these findings are also
mirrored across several additional
large-scale studies a negative HPV test
resulted in at least half the three and
five-year risk of both CA and 3 or
greater and in cervical cancer than
cytology additionally HPV 16 and 18
genotyping provides greater risk
stratification not only identifying
women with the highest probability of
having an underlying high-grade lesion
of baseline but also over the screening
interval in Athena one in four women
with a baseline hpv-16 positive result
develops di and 3 or greater within
three years although lower than the HPV
16 positive women HPV 18 positive women
were still at it statistically higher
risk of developing CIN 3 or greater then
those positive for the 12 other
high-risk types exceeding ten percent
for cin 3 within three years i'm in
positive for h for the other 12
high-risk HPV types are two
substantially lower risk for cin 3 or
greater reaching about 5% risk within
three years
whereas HPV status will predict which
women who are essential free from risk
HPV genotyping more accurately predicts
which women will subsequently develop
high grade cervical cancer precursors
this risk stratification better assesses
a woman's need for immediate colposcopy
and helps balance the rates of referral
to disease case detected as we try to
simplify how we screen by introducing
each piece of introducing primary HPV
screening a consideration must be made
as to when to initiate screening in 2011
the 2011 us screening guidelines did not
recommend HPV testing for women 25 to 29
unless it was used as a reflex tenaska
cytology this is largely because HPV
infections are common in this age group
and are typically transient however in
the interim guidance document that was
just published the professional
societies did acknowledge that there is
a high burden of cin 3 in this age group
and cytology which is so far the only
option performs poorly in this
population but because these these
recommendations are departure from the
previous guide guidelines there are a
few questions that should be addressed
why include women 25 to 29 how is high
prevalence of high risk HPV and
referrals and then referrals to cope
Oscar be balanced in this age group and
what consideration should be made around
regression of high-grade disease and
young women so first let's take a look
at the incidence of cervical cancer by
age group in the u.s. data from the
National Cancer Institute's dear tumor
registry shows that a sharp rise in the
incidence of cervical case invasive
cervical cancer occurs between the age
of
15 and 30 for cervical cancer screening
is unique in that we can detect and
manage cervical cancer precursors before
cervical cancer develops so the ultimate
goal of cervical cancer screening is not
to detect cancer but to prevent the
diagnosis of cervical cancer this
suggests that the initiation of
screening should ideally occur during
the sharp increase in cervical cancer
incidence just prior to the peak and
practice we do screen women over the age
of 21 but the question is are we
screening effectively in Athena the
large-scale us-based registration trial
reference in the guidance document a
third of all identified cervical
pre-cancer 'he's in women 25 years and
older were found in women 25 to 29 years
of age to put this into perspective
let's look at this let's put these
numbers based on population size so in
fact more hiker high-grade disease was
found in the six thousand six hundred
and forty seven women in this five-year
age range than in any other age group
this demonstrates that the highest
disease burden is in women 25 to 29 and
keep in mind this age range is also at
this at the start of the sharp incline
and cervical cancer diagnosis so are we
effective in current screening practices
remember the 2011 screening guidelines
recommended that the preferred method
for screening women 30 years and older
is a combined cytology in an HPV test
meaning that these women basically have
a safety net with incorporation of HPV
testing
for women 25 to 29 cytology is still the
only method according to the 2011
screening guidelines but cytology which
is a standard of care fail to detect
more than fifty six percent of cervical
pre-cancer 'he's in women 25 to 29 this
is more than any other age group and in
an age range that has the highest burden
of cervical cancer or cervical
pre-cancer it suggests that current
screening with cytology is inadequate in
identifying underlying cin 3 or greater
it simply is not sensitive enough but if
we simply screen for HPV effectively
increasing sensitivity a large
proportion of women may be referred for
follow-up testing as expected HPV
positivity the highest and the youngest
age group and declines with age in
Athena about twenty one percent of women
25 to 29 years of age for high risk HPV
positive so how can we balance this high
prevalence of high risk HPV and
referrals to colposcopy in this age
group one way to reduce reduce immediate
referrals is to focus on the group of
women that are at the highest risk of
cervical cancer women that are positive
for HPV 16 or 18 in Athena only by seven
percent of women 25 to 29 were positive
for one of these two genotypes and in
comparison the proportion of women 25 to
29 they were positive for 16 and 18 is
actually smaller than the total number
with abnormal psychology results for
that same age range
by simply using HPV 16 and 18 genotyping
for women 25 to 29 which is the smallest
group of women with the highest
association to cervical pre-cancer would
be referred for media colposcopy with
this shift in screening strategy for
women 25 to 29 look how much better we
can do we can increase the effectiveness
of screening by detecting thirty percent
more cin 3 or greater cases than by
psychology and that's just for HPV 16
and 18 positive cases incorporating the
12 other high-risk HPV types will
improve the detection of cin 3 or
greater even further and it's important
to note that high-grade disease found in
young women is more likely associated
with HPV 16 than any other genotype and
the mean age of an HPV 16 positive cin 3
or greater lesion is below the age of 30
hpv16 positives 293 was more commonly
diagnosed in younger women versus older
women further highlighting the
effectiveness of genotyping and
screening younger women in fact even if
even in the very youngest age group so
these women are 13 to 24 which
presumably have the highest overall
clearance rates HPV 16 and 18 lesions
are less likely to regress the non HPV
16 and 18 1 but if we take this a step
further we can look at the overall
effectiveness of various screening
methods including women 25 to 29 in
discussions of cervical cancer screening
and screening modalities the recent ACS
a sec PA SCP cervical cancer screening
guidelines of 2011
specifically acknowledge that the
benefits of screening should be balanced
between the potential harms with the
total number of colposcopy serving as a
surrogate measure of harms the Athena
study provides an opportunity to
evaluate both the benefit and potential
harms of screening when various
combinations of cytology a high risk HPV
testing and genotyping for HPV 16 and 18
are used to develop screening algorithms
for women 25 years and older for
simplicity sake the focus will be on
three algorithms supported by us
screening guidelines the first is
cytology which relies on HPV testing to
triage ascus results for women 25 years
and older the second is a co testing
strategy relying on a one-year co test
rescreen of women with normal normal
cytology and HPV positive results keep
in mind that this co testing strategy is
only for women 30 years and older and
the third screening modality is the
primer HPV screening algorithm supported
by SG oh and a sec p as a screening
option for women 25 years and older
because the analysis evaluate the
performance in two age groups so women
25 years and older and women 30 years
and older certain modifications to the
co testing screening algorithm need to
be accounted for for women 25 years and
older hybrid strategy is used which
combines the cytology method for women
25 to 29 and with the co testing
algorithm for women 30 years in older
women 30 years and older are essentially
only Co tested
when comparing the effectiveness or
efficiency of the screening methods we
can look at the number of cin 3 or
greater lesions detected and the number
of kalpas capiz performed and more
specifically the number of colposcopy s
that would be required to be will be
required to be performed / disease case
detected for women 25 years and older
primary HPV screening detected nearly
forty percent more cin 3 or greater at
baseline than either of the two
screening methods the superior
performance extends over the three years
with more than twenty percent or greater
than twenty percent more cin 3 or
greater cases detected than the hybrid
strategy and sixty-four percent more
than cytology for women 25 years and
older for women 30 years and older
primary HPV screening detected nearly
thirty percent more see 93 or greater
cases at baseline and either of the two
screening methods by year three it
detected fifty percent more CI + 3 or
greater cases and cytology and the co
testing method nearly caught up but keep
in mind that many of these subsequent
cases may remain undetected remain
undetected if a loss to follow-up is a
concern in clinical practice other
higher than cytology the number of copas
capiz performed / identified case of
stay and 3 or greater for primer HPV
screening was nearly identical to the
hybrid strategy for both age groups
but how did this screening compare or
how does this perform in women 25 to 29
by extending HPV primary screening down
page 25 from 30 a hundred and two
additional cin 3 or greater cases are
detected versus only 51 by cytology this
is exactly twice the number of cin three
cases detected by primary HPV screening
and cytology with this increased
sensitivity the number of kalpas capiz
would naturally also increase by
including women 25 to 29 1247 additional
colposcopy so will be performed with
primary HPV screening however this is
actually less than twice the number of
additional colposcopy performed
following cytology this means that the
higher proportional gain is cin 3 or
graders and sensitivity for women 25 to
29 action makes the colposcopy is
performed more efficient in a primary
HPV screening method in other words 8
HPV primer HPV screaming identifies more
cases of CI and 3 or greater than
cytology while requiring fewer
colposcopy spurt disease case detective
for women 25 to 29 proving that HPV
primary screening is the most effective
screening strategy for this age group in
a similar vein if we add cytology
testing for women 25 to 29 to the code
testing hybrid strategy essentially
bring that age group down to the number
of colposcopy is needed to detect each
cn3 case actually to decrease compared
to primer HPV screening indicating or
shifted indicating a lower efficiency
this is mainly due to the Signet to the
significant
my fewer cases of cin three cases
detected one relying on cytology for
this age group as we try to improve how
we screen by introducing primary primer
HPV screening a consideration must be
made as to when to initiate or begin
this this new screening method there is
a high burden of cin 3 in women 25 to 29
and cytology which is the current
standard of care performs poorly in this
population HPV testing increases the
sensitivity and detection of these
high-grade lesion and strategies are
relying on HPV 16 and 18 genotyping can
affect effectively stratify risk and
limit referrals to colposcopy the rate
of kalpas capiz is actually not an
accurate measure of potential harms of
screening its risks associated with
procedures and treatments accompanying
these may actually have been overstated
and it's also important to consider that
there must be a threshold for which a
colposcopy is acceptable even for women
25 to 29 it may be the potential
discomfort and anxiety associated with a
follow-up procedure is tolerated if the
alternative is a missed precancerous
lesion it's clear that cervical cytology
appears to have reached the point where
it alone is unable to reduce cervical
cancer rates further the benefits of HPV
primary screening include the increased
detection of cervical pre-cancer
detection of cervical cancer precursors
especially in women 25 to 29 the best
balance of benefits and harms of using
HPV testing as a first-line primary
screen there's a triage strategy that
includes an int
graded HPV 16 and 18 result with
cytology of the 12 other high-risk HPV
genotypes primary HPV testing is now on
alternative alternative option to
current cytology based screening methods
due to equivalent or superior
effectiveness and with that I want to
thank you all for your attention I'm
going to pass it back over to duty so
hopefully we can get to some of your
questions and if all the questions
aren't answered I give you my full
promise that I will address each one
individually thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on a question and answer session
i would like to remind our audience how
to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try the
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is does the FDA
approved HPV test test only HPV 16 and
18 not other high-risk strains I think I
have a hard time hearing the volume is
not really working I think the question
was the FDA approved 16 and 18 only so
the FDA approval for primary HPV
screening includes all 14 high-risk
genotypes that's basically standard for
an HPD test nowadays where the FDA
approval was a little bit more specific
is that they had to consider this
balance between excessive HPV positivity
and the management of women for
colposcopy so the algorithm or the
approvals for the FDA wasn't in court
operation of HPV 16 and 18 simultaneous
genotyping to the detection of the
remainder of the high-risk HPV types so
in total we're looking at all 14
high-risk types and we're getting a
result for all of those but the 16 and
18 women are uniquely identified at the
same time okay next to all women with 16
or 18 will they eventually develop
cervical cancer so that's an interesting
question and actually being 16 positive
or 18 positive doesn't mean you will
develop cervical cancer what it will
kind of help a clinician decide and a
patient to decide is how high your
potential risk is cervical cancer is
still fairly rare in this country and
only a small subset will actually reach
that stage of invasive cervical cancer
but by knowing your genotype you also
understand start to learn what your
risks are over the next few years women
that are positive for HPV 16 and HPV 18
are at a higher risk but not it doesn't
not necessarily mean the cancer is
inevitable and that's why it's really
important to talk to your doctor about
strategies and management and follow-up
just to make sure that those women are
followed accordingly to again to help
prevent invasive cervical cancer from
developing
okay now I asked how is the HPV testing
done is it a blood draw tissue what are
the costs compared to pap smear so right
now all HPV testing is done on the
similar sample as a pap smear or PAP
collection so that hasn't changed there
is new research and studies looking at a
vaginal collection or even a self
collection but that is not fda-approved
those type of collections it is not yet
a blood test I unfortunately can't
really address the the costs because I
think there's going to be a lot of
that's going to be dependent both in
terms of the individual HPV tests
reimbursements and things like that so
fortunately I cannot address that
portion of the question okay how are the
other 12 HR types reported and used by
the clinician I'm sure so I can I'll
speak to the cobas HPV test which is the
Roche test and the one that's approved
for FDA approved for primary HPV
screening this test looks or is designed
to detect 14 high-risk HPV genotypes how
it's designed is that in this pool of 14
it will actually individually look for
an HPV 16 and an HPV 18 and then look to
see what other 12 high-risk HPV
genotypes are present labs actually have
their own way of reporting results to
clinicians most labs using the call box
HPV test will provide an HPV 16 years
old which could be 18 or
salt and then also result for those 12
other high-risk HPV genotypes so in
essence you have a result for all 14 but
with specific reports for 16 and 18 are
HPV are missed HPV plus cases in women
25 to 29 due to the lack of paps being
perform for this age range or does the
pet actually perform more poorly in
these instances yeah so a lot of that is
largely unknown pap and cytology
performance really depends on an
adequate sampling and an adequate
collection of the transformation zone or
that portion of the cervix where HPV and
cervical cancer develops women at
different stages of their I guess their
life cycle I hate just use that word but
a different stages of their lives will
have actually a different shape of the
cervix and it may be the younger women
are have their transformation zone or
the collection site is a lot less
accessible and when you rely on a very
low a test with very low sensitivity any
sort of complications or limitations
with collection is going to have a much
greater impact than if you were using a
very highly sensitive test and so by
using HPV testing instead of cytology
you can kind of overcome any sort of
collection bias or or collection
limitations again because it's much more
sensitive and looking for the specific
cause or the specific virus that will
lead to cervical cancer
another one for you is the FDA approval
for the Roche HR HPV testing only or is
it accepted to test with other methods
examples service etc so so the sgo and a
sec p guidance document lab was actually
really clear on the fact that an
fda-approved SI for the specific
indication which is primary HPV testing
should be used the reason is that each
of these HPV tests that are available
and therefore that are currently
fda-approved in general all have
slightly different performance
characteristics so without that that
evaluation by the FDA its you can't
assume equivalency between them an FDA
will specifically evaluate these assays
for safety and the low risk of
developing see I'm 3 or greater over a
long time over a longer period so
without that basically that stamp of a
confirmation of safe dates it's very
difficult to say that you can use any
other test the next question is a
two-parter does the FDA labeling require
cytology as a reflex to HPV positive non
1618 results and second part to all HPV
positive patients go directly to
colposcopy or just 18 of 1618 positive
yeah so that's a good question the FDA
approval actually looks a lot like the
guidance the algorithm that was provided
in the guidance document by st honesty
GP there is a 16 and 18 I've genotyping
those women are referred immediately for
colposcopy because they are the highest
risk for having an underlying or even
developing a cervical pre-cancer within
the three year interval but the 12 other
high-risk HPV genotypes because there is
a concern with sending every woman
hpv-positive to colposcopy there has to
be a little bit of a balance there the
vast majority of women who test
hpv-positive will actually be positive
for the 12 other high-risk types and not
16 and 18 so these women are actually or
the collection of these women are
actually triage through cytology and
cytology will look at those samples and
determine which ones actually have
underlying or current cell abnormalities
detected by cytology and those women are
at the highest risk in that little pool
and they are referred to Koh PHA skippy
so and the women with the 12 other HPV
positive but our pep negative so without
any detectable cellular changes are we
screened in a year and again it's really
to help balance this high rate of HPV
positivity with the need for colposcopy
so essentially what we're doing is
identifying the women at the highest
risk and those women who should be
immediately evaluated those were the
lower risk can be deferred because the
progression to cervical cancer is
actually fairly slow and so that's how
that balance works there's absolutely a
cytology component without it there
would just be a large proportion being
sent to colposcopy
your next one is what is the false
negative rate of the kielbasa HPV test
and I didn't quite catch that the false
negative rate so what we're looking for
here is the detection of disease and
really what a negative result means this
is always assessed based on the current
standard of care or the threshold of
care and that's cytology the benefit of
an HPV test is really to detect more of
those cin three cases that are just
missed by psychology to determine a
false negative it's actually pretty hard
for and for cervical cancer screening
because there's a lot of subjectivity
that goes into disease ascertain meant
not only a psychology very subjective
but colposcopy and potential biopsies at
time of colposcopy czar so highly
subjective and without sampling and the
entire cervix and just basically
excising all of it to look for any sort
of disease it's very hard to taxi put
that into perspective what we do look at
is how well each test and each algorithm
is a detecting high grade disease that's
detectable in this case an HPV negative
case or the kobus HPV test there was
about a point three percent risk of
having a cin 3 or greater detected
within three years which again is half
the risk of cytology
your next question is what races are
represented in you presented statistics
I don't think I quite heard that I think
the question was what races were
represented so Athena specifically was a
general screening population and
actually the distribution of women and
the demographics of the Athena actually
matches the general US population next
question is um how can HP be how can HPV
testing help detect a is so HPV testing
the benefit of HPV testing is really the
higher sensitivity and there are studies
that are have been published looking at
HPV testing versus cytology in the
detection of AIS and adenocarcinoma it's
actually significantly higher than what
you detect by cytology again cytology is
really dependent on adequate sampling
and correct sampling to detect these
kind of lesions and because they are the
cytology so much less sensitive it's
even more influenced by collection and
adequate collection HPV testing because
you're looking for the presence of the
virus you actually need only a few cells
that are affected to really be able to
identify women at risk so there is less
of a threshold to overcome with an HPV
test to detect these type of lesions
okay um you have a bunch more questions
coming in and so I'm just going to pause
for a moment to allow to allow the next
question to pass through so bear with me
one moment here and and i will share
another question with you you're
actually you're getting a flood of
questions and just there with us for a
moment and i think we'll just have time
probably for one more question so we're
just sifting through to to determine
that last question see here we go in a
second here all right in the case of a
negative HPV result how do you know that
the transformation zone has been sampled
and that it is a true negative HPV I'm
sorry Judy can I pass it back to you I
didn't quite hear the question
absolutely okay in the case of a
negative HPV result how do you know that
the transformation zone has been sampled
and that it is a true negative HPV hope
that's that is it okay sorry about that
I heard it this time um so i can again i
can speak to the cobas HPV test
specifically for 10 so this
question the cobas test hasn't built
getting feedback I've built in a
cellular internal control so that
actually tells a clinician or a
laboratory that cells have been
collected and have been sampled it looks
for beta globin which is present in all
human cells and that will provide either
a valid or invalid result if there is
insufficient cells or there is no human
cells or are no human cells present you
can get an invalid result if the HPV is
negative unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their interesting questions and
participation in today's event any
questions not address live during the
allotted time will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration for
more information we would like to invite
you to visit w WH PV 16 and 18 com I
would also like to thank our sponsor
roche molecular diagnostics for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May tenth
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for a replay we invite you to
afford that announcements your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye